rouge gorge une quipe jules
derrière ses marques il y a le groupe
fâche un tube composantes de l'empiré
mulliez fondateur d'auchan sa chaîne
youtube emblème de la fast fashion avec
ses vêtements fabriqués en asie et un
modèle économique qui causait la perte
de l'industrie textile en europe
mais impensable le même groupe s'apprête
à relever qu'alizé une partie de sa
production en france
[Musique]
la future usine la voici elle se situe
près de pourquoi
impossible d'y mettre les pieds elle est
encore en construction mais d'ici la fin
2022 cent trente mille jean vont aussi
être fabriqué trois cent mille à l'année
prochaine
[Musique]
au siège du groupe christian kinnen est
un peu le monsieur madeinfrance
responsable de la relocalisation bien
mise en avant sur youtube
on est cher que le premier gmail et nord
sera le 5 nov en hommage à la région tu
suis pas fier de leur projet pourtant ce
retour en france reste modeste
l'entreprise ne va fabriquer que 6% de
ses pantalons dans la nouvelle usine une
goutte d'eau dans l'océan des
importations
le marché global du jeans en france est
estimé à 88 million de jeans écoulés
chaque année depuis ses tout petits en
un temps c'est significatif est ce qu'on
veut c'est finalement amorcer la pompe
de la relocalisation démontrer qu'il est
possible de faire des jeans qui sont
dans nos gammes de prix qui s'adressent
à notre clientèle actuelle et que nos
clients sont prêts à acheter dès lors on
pourra donner une toute autre ampleur à
la démarche ce pantalon va coûter 50 9
euros
un peu plus que le prix actuel en
magasin lusine devrait embaucher 50
personnes d'ici fin 2022 une centaine
dans deux ans des prototypes sont déjà
en production en attendant voilà le
premier jean quand tu vois il n'y a pas
encore les boutons est pas encore arrivé
vingt-cinq couturière recruté pour un
process semi automatisé loin des caméras
les couturières sont en formation
qu'elles se sont entraînés à faire
chacun des morceaux qui nous permet
d'identifier les savoir faire de chacun
les différentes étapes de production ce
qu'on est capable de faire pendant des
années l'industrie textile à délocaliser
au nom du prix le plus bas est ce que
c'est en train de changer
l'industrie textile a délocalisé à la
recherche d'économies de valeur incités
par les pouvoirs publics sur le sujet
puisque à un moment donné des pouvoirs
publics nous ont dit qu'ils n'avaient
pas de droit de douane dans tel était le
pays donc à amplifier finalement ce
mouvement naturel de délocalisation
aujourd'hui ce que nous on lance c'est
une démarche qui est à l'opposé de ça
qui est de réfléchir comment on fabrique
le produit et comment on rend la
fabrication d'un produit dans les pays
de consommation
économiquement
supportable pour les consommateurs des
pays dans lesquels on produit ça veut
dire que on est probablement en train
d'écrire une nouvelle page de
l'industrie de la confection textile
une france sans usines une france
dépendantes
la pénurie de masques au départ de la
crise qu vide a été un électrochoc
d'un coup d'un seul la france mesure est
son incapacité à produire des biens
essentiels sa vacuité industriel ici
reste que nous sous clé dans les mois
j'en ai dans mon bureau dans un placard
qui ferment à clé j'aime moins six
boîtes parce que parce qu'il faut garder
les stocks crise sanitaire triste de
l'énergie crise climatique
jamais l'expression de souveraineté
économique n'a autant été employée par
les politiques même certains chefs
d'entreprise change de logiciel
rend compte que le système d'aller
chercher toujours de la main d'oeuvre
moins chère enfin si tu n qui atteint
ses limites et des entreprises
relocalise
d'autres essaient de produire davantage
en france mais comment être compétitif
on peut faire des produits sympas en
france avec pour objectif de de
concurrencer le mag la dèche
l'industrie manufacturière a perdu huit
cent mille emplois en deux décennies
va-t-elle trouver la main d'oeuvre pour
faire tourner les usines là c'était
vingt ans qu'on a arrêté six à qui
devient difficile ça n'aurait jamais dû
être difficile donc quand vous avez une
vraie filière il faut pas l'enterrer il
faut la préserver pour la soigner pour
la cultiver
plan de relance loi climat et résilience
nouvelles aspirations des consommateurs
les entreprises textiles vont être
obligés d'innover
certaines choisissent de parier sur des
fibres oublié oui on peut dire que c'est
la révolution textile c'est un peu un
retour aux sources on a on a peut-être
quelque part fini de belp
voyage au coeur des usines textiles
celles qui ont survécu celles qui
reviennent
sailly sur la lys est un peu à l'image
du nord
un spectacle de désolation industrielle
au cours des années 90 et 2000 des
centaines de milliers d'emplois ont été
détruits dans le textile
la dernière filature de lin de la région
a été délocalisée il y a dix huit ans
ici ne reste plus guère que le siège
social et fernand donc faire non il a 40
ans de maison c'est ça
quarante grandes sociétés c'est notre
plus ancien collaborateur
donc il a connu tu as connu à côté la
friche à l'ancienne usine désaffectée
fernand réceptionne désormais les
bobines venus d'ailleurs
l'entreprise sa fille l'un a déménagé sa
filature en pologne elle y emploie 500
personnes
et sernin du sifer
a été difficile pour convertir en
pologne mais bon c'était
c'était comme ça c'était horrible
c'était inévitable
c'était texte-là débuté
c'était
et puis plus tard
préfet tout un moment de nostalgie
les gens carter et de la société
la baisse d'activité a mis dix ans pour
pour se clôturer la dernière bobine de
fil ci a été produite en 2005
les affaires marchent bien en europe de
l'est le fils de l'un se vend de mieux
en mieux l'entreprise veut augmenter sa
production mais plutôt que de s'agrandir
en pologne elle va faire autrement à
quelques kilomètres de là à béthune sa
fille l'un revient en france en
remontant une usine version 21e siècle
donc là les faca sportivement ont
terminé aux idiomes dirige sa fille lien
entre la pologne et la france on est
quand même déjà bien avancé là
ce jour là il a l'oeil sur tout dans
quatre semaines les premières bobines de
fil vont sortir de l' usine
30 métiers à filer et autres machines
sont déjà arrivés de pologne sur 6000 m²
d'ateliers flambant neuf
on ré industrialiser ça veut dire qu'on
remet des outils de production on
réembauche des gens on forme des gens
qui voulaient de filature de lin ça
demande énormément d'intervention
humaine et à la mécanique à la machine
qui fait son travail mais il ya le
regarde de l'opérateur son intervention
des gestes qu'il faut acquérir pour
rattacher le fils lorsqu'il casse leur
passé au bon endroit donc il ya vraiment
tout un une gestuelle importante à
acquérir l'entreprise a recruté une
trentaine de salariés suffisant pour
produire 350 mille tonnes de fil par an
avec alix et caledon que les trois jours
d'accueil formation partout on fronce
l'industrie peine à recruter pourtant
ici malgré un salaire dans gauche plutôt
bas un simple smic safina a eu un
argument massue
n'ont jamais de parler de dates et rémy
devait être à durée déterminée en
acquittant connaissez des lits et c'est
peut-être pour ça que dans le sud est
marqué par rapport à d'autres sociétés
ne doit pas messieurs olivier guillaume
pense que produire en france c'est
désormais possible
cette relocalisation l'obligera à
facturer 20% de plus son fils à ses
clients qu'ils fabriquent tissus des
vêtements
ceci ne l'inquiète pas
car ces mêmes clients sont selon lui en
train de changer totalement de façon de
faire
la bonne elle en train de se repenser
premier avoir conçu reproduit une bonne
partie des produits qui ont un coût de
production sont orientés quasi sûr vers
les soldes d'après 40% des produits qui
finit sans solde et tous ne trouve pas
preneur et parfois son esprit est donc
si on fait l'équation on se rend compte
que finalement produire plus proche mais
en quantités
commercialisables et bien on n'est
finalement pas plus cher ou pas beaucoup
plus cher que commandait les grosses
quantités à l'import
ce retour au front ce n'est pas un pari
aussi risqué car le lin est
l'illustration parfaite
d'une absurdité moderne
imaginez-vous plus de 85% de la culture
mondiale de la plante de l'ain et
française à l'opposé du coton cultivé en
asie et gourmand en eau le lin est
vraiment écolo
aberrante réalité d'un commerce
mondialisé depuis 20 ans cette plante
française est envoyé à l'autre bout du
monde pour y être filet
avec le retour d'une usine dans le nord
un circuit court est à nouveau possible
chez sa fille l'an
la matière première arrive de normandie
dans notre usine on transforme la fibre
longue en ruban donc d'abord lé peigné
puis est tiré et c'est ce ruban qui est
la matière première en fait pour faire
le fil qui va être étiré et transformé
en mesh et donc cette mèche avec un peu
d'eau pour aller chercher de la finesse
va devenir du fil
bonne nouvelle pour sa fille là les
marques de vêtements vont être
encouragés à préférer les circuits
courts la loi climat et résilience et
des directives européennes sont en train
de créer une notation du textile 2 a à d
comme le nutrisse corps dans
l'alimentation en fonction de leur
impact environnemental ce qui est sûr
c'est avec les marques vont devoir s'y
conformer de gré ou de force pour
l'instant ces deux degrés les grands
groupes commencent à sérieusement
travaillé ces questions de traçabilité
puisque ce qui est sur la base du
volontariat aujourd'hui il va être une
obligation légale très rapidement
le futur étiquetage va inciter à rien dû
se réaliser dans le secteur textile
pour autant des filières entières ont
été démantelés et la tâche peut paraître
insurmontable
en alsace sur la route des vins une
marque de chaussettes presque centenaire
est une usine à rome labonal
son patron un oiseau rare s'est battu
pour ne jamais perdre au cabinet
ou pas ça
ce jour-là il y souffle un vent nouveau
dominique malfait vient de racheter des
machines
[Musique]
réinvestir cela ne lui était pas arrivé
depuis des années
la bâche au total il en a pour un peu
plus d'un million d'euros il a été aidé
pour 375 euros par l'état et la région
alors c'est le j'espère le début d'une
longue histoire qu'on
que c'est une première machine qu'on
fait rentrer la dot qui vont qui vont
suivre parce qu'un messi à tricoter et
qui devrait rentrer d'ici la fin du mois
cette machine sans plan de relance nous
l'aurions quand même pris parce qu'elle
est elle est intéressante pour nous mais
c'est plus rassurant que de se sentir
soutenu soutenu par l'état pour ce type
d'investissement
le moment est mémorable car entre hotton
de combat pour sauver 90 emplois
dominique malfait n'a jamais vu autant
d'engouement pour le made in france
en 2020 labonal a même fabriqué des
masques quand la france en manquait
depuis deux ans les comptes sont
repassés au vert mais difficile
d'obtenir des prêts pour étoffer le parc
de machines et innover aux yeux des
banques l'entreprise portent encore les
stigmates du passé
nous il ya cinq ans on était en
redressement judiciaire donc on est en
plan de continuation et aujourd'hui
lorsque vous êtes en prendre une
entreprise française qu'un plan de
coordination eh ben on est un peuple
acquis c'est pendant les par les banques
c'est à dire que les banques il dit
devant atteindre vous êtes pour nous
vous êtes toujours entreprises en
difficulté donc sortez de votre plan le
plan ça dure dix ans et et après on
verra ce que ce qu'on fait et ne peut
pas attendre dix ans quand même qu'à 35
ans il faut aller tout de suite c'est le
moment d'y aller
ici des ouvrières au responsable
logistique tous ont le sentiment de
coller à l'air du temps
avec la crise sanitaire les gens ont
vraiment senti le besoin de ne plus
dépendre des pays de l'étranger et
d'avoir vraiment une production
relocaliser et surtout qui n'avaient
plus l'impact environnemental et ceci
est au niveau la société qui s'appelait
impliqué
au prix de l'énergie et retards de
livraison du film rythment le quotidien
de dominique membres
comme tout le monde est confronté à
cette
cette pénurie de la promesse la première
donc là on essaye de rattraper le retard
pour implanter le printemps-été
22 et on a encore de grosses livraisons
par semaine pour augmenter ses capacités
de production
le patron doit garder ses salariés sur
ce post en particulier
pénible et répétitif
alors il a décidé d'instaurer davantage
de polyvalence dans l'entreprise
mais la crise qu vide a aussi fait venir
à lui de nouveaux cv
nathalie 53 ans travaillait dans la
restauration
depuis deux ans elle trouve que
l'industrie a finalement certains
avantages 22h28 est tous pareils surtout
par le sarm du dimanche se retrouvent
une vie de famille mais qui voit les
patrons et du monde a du mal à trouver
pour venir faire travailler des salariés
à l'usiné qu'est ce que vous en pensez
que c'est qu'actuellement c'est plus
compliqué comment cela rouvre du monde
aujourd'hui actuelle c'est bon
c'est à dire
personnes travaillent en slip sur les
jeunes ne veulent tous travaillent aussi
difficile d'attirer de la main d'oeuvre
bon marché ici dans le bas rhin où le
taux de chômage est plus bas qu'ailleurs
dominique malfait se réjouit du retour
en france de certaines usines d'ailleurs
il se fournit chez sa fille à la
filature qui revient dans nord mais ce
patron reste très sceptique sur la
capacité de la france à réindustrialiser
à grande échelle
dire en tenue mais le mal était fait
95% de la production en chaussettes et
délocaliser c'est pas demain qu'on va
fabriquer 50 % des chaussettes en france
il faut faire prendre conscience qu aux
consommateurs comme un produit formel en
france coûtera de toute façon plus cher
qu'un produit des vocalises et
une paire de chaussettes qui sort de
cette usine coûte 3 euros celle qui
arrive du bangladesh 50 centimes
impossible d'être compétitif sauf si le
prix du transport devient exponentielle
et ça pourrait bien arriver avec la
crise sanitaire et celle de l'énergie un
container utilisé pour l'import coûte 7
fois plus cher qu il y a quelques mois
pour se développer l'industrie textile
française va devoir innover et c'est ce
que certains industriels font déjà
surprise au salon première vision
l'événement mondial des professionnels
de la filière mode un fabricant français
un autre amoureux du lin est venu avec
dans son panier des objets insolites
canadienne qui est très légère en
général et en carbone ou en fibre de
verre si vous blesser bon le métier ni
nerfs comme ça pour me protéger c'est
juste pour montrer tout ce qu'on
préférait ça si court à ces bilans voila
voila c'est aussi simple que cela et au
départ la matière première c'est ça
après il ya on peut faire des membranes
peut le traiter de différentes manières
l'aca a été traitée avec la résine peut
par définition tout le placé pour y
remplacer avec ceinture et on a la
matière première
avec le lin pierre schmitt promet un
avenir meilleur au textile français mais
à certaines conditions
on peut pas innover loin des hommes est
loin des usines a tous bien vous venez
pas innové en délocalisant à dix mille
kilomètres comment innover pour innover
il faut une complicité d'une confiance
il faut une culture commune et tout ça
vous l'avez pas comment délocaliser donc
ce si simple l'innovation a disparu en
même temps que la délocalisation
donc on a cru vraiment je dirais que
c'était la solution a fait on s'est tiré
une balle dans les airs tony niveau
des usines pierre schmitt 69 ans en a
sauvé plusieurs
celle ci par exemple il ya huit ans
cette usine textile était menacée de
fermeture
ici
des machines à tisser
[Musique]
des techniques presque oubliée des
savoir faire
[Musique]
unique en france
le patron s'est appuyé sur thierry buts
62 ans qui a mis eux aussi nationalement
la fibre de lin
quand on parle de la en dans
l'imaginaire collectif on s'imagine la
la la la nappe de la grand-mère
les vieux draps tigres at elle du
grand-père dans les écoles textile c'est
une fibre qui avait été oublié
dans l' usine le travail de cette fibre
presque oublié est une sorte d'artisanat
industriels
on sent on sent le côté naturel sans vie
confie t on cela l'humidité et de penser
que toute cette fibre avec laquelle on
peut tout faire que ce soit des produits
d'habillement des produits d'ameublement
ou maintenant les produits techniques
pour les voitures pour l'isolation et
tout ça que tout ça part en chine
souhaite revaloriser c'est vraiment un
gâchis ya pas de bons gars chez total
pour éviter ce gâchis pour ne plus
fabriquer que de l'habillement aussi
pierre schmitt se lance dans un chantier
immense et il commande de plus en plus
de fibres
ce jour là dans un des bureaux qui
jouxte l'atelier justement un producteur
de l'ain venu de normandie
chez lui aussi misé sur le fait que
demain le lin pourrait remplacer la
fibre de verre par exemple dans tout ce
qu'on appelle les matériaux composites
un matériau composite c'est un renfort
textile
qui est lié par une résine donc
aujourd'hui cédée il ya des produits
tous les jours qu'ils sont faits en
composites autour de nous c'est les skis
c'est les baignoires c'est les
carrosseries train les carrosseries de
camions à plein plein de choses
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on va prendre un
matériau qu'on va renforcé de fibres en
fait on peut mettre
potentiellement dulin si on répond
techniquement j'irai au besoin c'est la
chimie et du tissu pour faire avancer
cet ambitieux projet pierre schmitt s'y
trouver des alliés ce soir-là son cabas
de fibres de l'an toujours en main le
patron se rend à mulhouse dans un
laboratoire de recherche publique il est
plutôt fier de collaborer avec des
scientifiques
enceinte au monde
je suis ravi d'être là toujours un grand
plaisir d'être dans ce labo
autour de la table jacques la baule et
vient d'embaucher un jeune chercheur
ingénieur pour une durée de cinq ans il
a obtenu une bourse de 450000 euros pour
travailler sur ces nouveaux matériaux
le potentiel pour de leurs pieds ou du
chambre du l'a donc le projet il va se
baser sur une meilleure compréhension de
l'interaction entre les fibres et la
chimie que l'on va mettre à la surface
pour améliorer les propriétés du fil
pour améliorer les propriétés du textile
voir ensuite les propriétés de renforts
que l'on peut amener grâce à ça mais
cette compréhension de l'interface entre
des fibres naturelles et les produits
chimiques qu'on va y ajouter n'est pas
quelque chose de bien connue
actuellement une recherche pleine de
promesses à l'heure où l'industrie va
devoir modifier beaucoup de nos produits
de consommation
[Musique]
l'idée c'est de petit à petit de passer
de polymères qui sont petro source et
parce que là la ressource de finir par
manquer tout ou tard à des polymères qui
sont bio sourcés et donc avoir une
empreinte environnementale nettement
moins importante de sorte à pouvoir à un
moment donné mais gagné ses fameux kg de
co2 ou ces tonnes de co2 qui qui nous
font cruellement défaut aujourd'hui qui
impactent fortement notre environnement
les projets industriels de pierre
schmitt et du laboratoire commence à
intéresser d'autres dirigeants
cet après-midi-là deux chefs
d'entreprise ont demandé à pierre
schmitt de visiter un de ses sites de
production textile et donc c'est
vrai que là vous avez donc d
une ancienne drame et ça c'est donc
toute nouvelle combien d installer ça
fait trois mois donc tout le matériel
bien dit aline à la marque s'appelle
unitec et
un homme et une femme est tout à fait
que l'on a un gros client allemand on a
à peu près comment de 200 mm donc ça
commence déjà à me réduit de rocroi et
une en train de livrer les
repas les deux visiteurs investissent
dans des industries de pointe comme les
biotechnologies n'est pas seulement la
légèreté du tissu les intéressent les
produits composites aussi pour un de
leurs projets phares
donc vous c'est le la en fait l'ancien
moulin
et les composites
bon ce sont des produits que l'on
souhaite utiliser dans l'une de nos
filiales
qui va développer des produits pour
l'aéronautique en hausse on va
travailler sur des drogues et son
désamour
via le plan de relance pierre schmidt va
toucher une aide de 2 millions d'euros
versé par l'état sur les 10 millions
qu'il doit investir pour innover
cela va mettre de l'huile dans les
rouages mais ce ne sera pas suffisant
ça peut paraître beaucoup mais dans la
globalité c'est très peu parce qu'en
fait on mesure pas je dirais le retard
qu'on a pris est en mesure pas tous les
investissements qu'il faut aujourd'hui
pour s'inscrit pour devenir un leader au
niveau du marché et surtout pas capable
de développer des nouveaux produits
comme les composites et tous les autres
produits
depuis 30 ans la france dépend d'une
économie basée sur le tertiaire les
services quand l'asie est devenue
l'atelier du monde c'était même une
spécificité choisi de nos économies
développées une hérésie selon pierre
schmitt
dans toute l'histoire économique et
culturel et historique d'un pays a
toujours eu de l'industrie je pense
qu'on a eu on a fait un lavage de
cerveau en faisant croire à tout le
monde qu'on pouvait vivre sans industrie
je pense que c'est du n'importe quoi on
l'a raconté n'importe quoi parce que à
un moment donné les services et
accessoires je dirais on a vu tous les
crises économiques dans les pays où une
antenne d'industrie ont été absolument
dramatique
le plan de relance de mars 2020 consacre
35 milliards d'euros à l'industrie
encourageant certaines entreprises à se
moderniser d'autres à relocaliser ou à
produire de façon plus durable
[Musique]